are also right now joined by uh magnus
carlsen it was
close magnus a huge comeback so how does
it feel to
not take it all the way
um well first of all really really uh
disappointed with uh with my performance
today
um obviously huge uh
congrats to jan and wishing best of luck
and
in the finals um but um
uh yeah i think uh yesterday
um felt felt bad but there was only like
really one stretch of the third game
where i felt like
i really could have done a lot better
today was really um was really very very
poor
and it's not
yeah it's not the kind of play that i i
want to
to show um at all
well uh the performance with winning two
in a row there to take it to tie breaks
was quite spectacular now
was it hard mentally then to shift from
sort of i have to win i have to win
winning
have to win winning and also pushing
then in the first blitz
game there uh quite long for for a win
and then having the white pieces in the
second one
now the thing is um i actually played
really
poorly in the in the first
in the in the first black game that i
had to win uh
i made several several blunders there
especially
early on and also also later
so i felt like um
it was more kind of um
um it was more kind of i think
him sort of stumbling there um rather
than me doing
something something great and i i mean
the uh the second game that i won on
demand
uh that was just um
yeah okay i played i played decently um
but i didn't have to make a single
difficult move so i don't think that was
anything special
uh but ultimately what decided um
decided the the match is that he managed
to keep his hot
head pretty calm in the in the in the
blitz and i most certainly did not
um and yeah i was obviously happy to get
to get to the blitz but i i still had
sort of a iffy feeling
because i knew that the job was far far
from from done and
i even if i'd won a couple of
of games there i feel felt like i i
still wasn't playing great and
and in his case he was still sort of
playing with um
house money there because he knew even
if even though he
um he had collapsed and lost the last
two games
he still could sort of start from from
scratch and um
in the tie breaks and magnus in the
you mentioned it yourself in the second
must-win game um in the rapids
you won quite convincingly was there a
reason you didn't repeat the same
strategy the same opening
um in the blitz games i'm sorry i can't
hear you guys now for some reason
oh can you hear us now testing yeah i
can hear you now
i think i accidentally muted
i mean it's probably better that way
david was saying
yeah i was just saying um magnus you
mentioned it yourself um
winning that second game on demand
and uh with the white pieces very
convincingly was there a reason you
didn't want to repeat the same opening
the same strategy in the blitz games
oh that's a that's a good question um
it's always sort of a very it's
it's a difficult decision to make there
whether
because i i mean i don't think he lost
because of the opening there
i think he just played really really
poorly there in the
in the early middle game and on the
other hand
um i i mean
peter had told me about this idea with
putting the knight on h5 in in the line
that he
he played in in my first white game
today and
i knew that it's somewhat risky but i
thought it looks looks
interesting um and i think
later on i mean there was nothing
particularly wrong wrong with that
i got a pleasant position with some
some chances to to push um
and uh yeah the fact that the fact that
i lost it
is something that that should should not
happen at all um
but yeah it was uh was not not about
the the opening but it's again it's it's
difficult
to make decisions at that point whether
you want to
challenge the line that he he played or
you want to play something like
um something quiet uh like the
london or thereabouts and you mentioned
peter heiner nielsen were you in contact
with him today or was that an idea that
you
discussed with him in the past no he
he told me about this idea before the
before the blitz now finally minus the
two players and the finals are two
players in the candidates tournament
they seem to be in great shape in this
tournament so are we basically seeing
the two uh
the two players in the best shape uh
going through to the final
and you know being in training camp mode
is one of the reasons why they're so
good
i think that would be drawing um
too many conclusions on very very noisy
data
[Laughter]
so
i mean wesley had been
pretty flawless up to this point and
there was nothing to
to suggest that um
he's not too thrilled right now about
playing for that third place